It's still a long way from a servant being able to appear before his master. I'm
sorry, young lady. I haven't
had many knives since the season. Oh, I've gotten some pocket money, so let's get some chicken and let's
boil it together. Do you want to go shopping?
[Music]  ] I wanted to
feed my father, but my
father is so amazing that there is no one better than him, but I don't know what I did wrong,
but because of my feelings of virtuousness, I was not able to
feed him in the first place.  Even though I don't have a job, I
live in
Ninja, so if I was going to make a deal, I'm sure
Baba, who is a skilled worker, would at least serve me food,
but why is he so silent?
[Music] Were you
even teasing me
?